[Música]
eeuu anunció que empezará a enviar un
pequeño número de tropas a europa
oriental mientras continúan los
esfuerzos diplomáticos para evitar un
conflicto entre rusia y ucrania
volodymyr sellent que llamó a occidente
a no generar pánico por la acumulación
de tropas en sus fronteras
sexto día consecutivo de votaciones
infructuosas en el parlamento de italia
para elegir al nuevo presidente del país
el partido democrático del mandatario
sergio mataré la busca de su continuidad
que él mismo descarta el proceso
continúa en medio de la profunda
división entre los partidos
el derrame de petróleo en las costas
peruanas habría sido de 11 mil 900
barriles y no de 6 mil como se informó
en un principio el gobierno de pedro
castillo resaltó que se trata de un
escenario ambiental sin precedentes y
denunció que la petrolera repsol no está
cumpliendo con las tareas de limpieza
bienvenidos a una nueva actualización de
noticias en france 24 yo soy daniel
hablando comenzamos hablando del
presidente de eeuu joe biden quien dijo
que enviara un pequeño número de tropas
al este de europa un anuncio que llega
mientras continúan los esfuerzos
diplomáticos para desescalar la crisis
de ucrania por su parte el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski ha instado
a los líderes occidentales a evitar que
cunda el pánico por la masiva
acumulación de tropas rusas en su
frontera
ha decidido cuando trasladará a las
tropas estadounidenses a europa del este
estaré trasladando tropas
estadounidenses a europa del este en los
países de la otan a corto plazo y
mientras tanto la incertidumbre se
apodera de heart como una ciudad
ucraniana fronteriza con rusia mientras
moscú acumula tropas en la zona a pesar
de los temores los efectivos liderados
por quiebren se preparan para enfrentar
una eventual invasión
es
como al borde de algo muy terrible y
aterrador
entonces si puedo decir que tengo miedo
que
este es el sentimiento que predomina en
hardcore ciudad ucraniana fronteriza con
rusia allí los habitantes viven en un
estado constante de alarma este
territorio está equipado con cámaras de
vigilancia para que podamos ver señales
tempranas de un ataque y podamos
advertir a las fuerzas armadas para que
envíen apoyo defensivo
los temores no son infundados rusia
acumula alrededor de 100 mil soldados
cerca de los bordes ucranianos el
ejército también se prepara en caso de
una invasión esta semana los efectivos
controlados por kiev realizaron
ejercicios militares utilizando los
misiles ante ataques recibidos por el
reino unido
cien por ciento que los tanques no
funcionarán porque ya tenemos muchas
armas antitanque si yo fuera el enemigo
definitivamente no usaría un tanque me
negaría
el presidente vladimir selenski
desestimó los temores declarando este
viernes que los medios posicionan la
idea que se desarrolló una guerra en su
país lo que golpea fuertemente la
economía nacional sin ser del todo
cierto al mismo tiempo la dimar putin
daba a conocer su inconformidad al
presidente francés emmanuel macrón a
decir del mandatario ruso eeuu y la otan
no han abordado las principales demandas
de seguridad de moscú pero que estaban
listos para seguir hablando
nos quedamos en europa porque el
estancamiento en el parlamento italiano
continúa este sábado después de que por
sexto día consecutivo los partidos
políticos no lograran un acuerdo para
elegir al presidente de este país el
actual primer ministro mario draghi es
uno de los principales candidatos para
el puesto también se baraja la
posibilidad de la continuidad de sergio
mataré la o incluso la llegada de una
mujer al cargo
al fin del lunes la misma historia se
desarrolla en el parlamento de italia
día tras día se cuentan las papeletas
para elegir el próximo presidente del
país y la conclusión es la misma
no se alcanzó la mayoría absoluta de los
integrantes de la asamblea es necesario
proceder a una nueva votación
los partidos de izquierda dicen que el
trabajo debería recaer en el actual
primer ministro mario draghi quien ha
sido aclamado por traer estabilidad al
país pero muchos temen que un cambio
abrupto del primer ministro a presidente
podría llevar al frágil gobierno de
coalición en italia al límite otros
bloques políticos se pelean por
encontrar un plan
el viernes los partidos de derecha
apoyaron a la presidenta del senado
elisabetta castle a ti no lo habíamos
candidata en cuanto dos no la elegimos
por ser mujeres sino como personalidad
institucional y profesional de confianza
funcionaria estatal con experiencia en
el ámbito judicial territorio de los
datos experiencia y más estructura en la
boca tuvo horas el ati miembro del
partido forza italia de berlusconi es
conocida por su oposición al aborto y
las uniones entre personas del mismo
sexo los partidos de izquierda tildan su
nominación de error casi la obtuvo solo
382 votos muy por debajo de los 505
necesarios para ganar
matar a él
matara en la
mientras tanto partes del movimiento
cinco estrellas están presionando para
que el presidente sergio matar ela se
quede pero el hombre de 80 años insiste
en que no quiere un segundo mandato se
acaba el tiempo para que el parlamento
encuentre su sustituto el periodo de
mataré la finalizará el 3 de febrero
y de europa nos vamos para el continente
africano al menos el 40 por ciento de la
población de la región etíope de tigre
necesita asistencia alimentaria urgente
según el programa mundial de alimentos
de naciones unidas se trata de unos 9
millones de personas una cifra récord
desde que en noviembre de 2020 inició el
conflicto entre el ejército etíope y el
frente popular de liberación que cree
que gobernaba esa región del norte del
país desde entonces la nación africana
entró en una crisis humanitaria sin
precedentes y la onu denuncia que sigue
sin poder transportar ayuda humanitaria
desde mediados de diciembre ya que no es
posible garantizar su seguridad
en noticias de américa latina' en perú
el gobierno cree que la cifra de
barriles derramados en una refinería
operada por la empresa española repsol
es mayor de lo que se creía según las
autoridades fueron cerca de 12 mil
barriles mucho más que los 26 mil
reportados inicialmente por la empresa
la transnacional le aseguró que el
número es menor y que se encuentra
limpiando el desastre el informe desde
manuel acabó
la cifra sigue aumentando
en perú las autoridades elevaron a
11.900 el número de barriles derramados
en las costas del país el gobierno
indicó que se trata de un escenario sin
precedentes en la historia de la nación
en el pasivo frontal y contundente al
afrontar esta crisis falta
tras este episodio
a través de todos los organismos la
realidad se está haciendo el trabajo que
no lo estaba haciendo una empresa en un
principio la empresa española repsol
había dicho que se trataba sólo de seis
mil barriles pero luego de la
información revelada por el ejecutivo
peruano emitió su propio balance
con la información técnica disponible
estamos en disposición de comunicar que
la cantidad de petróleo derramado es de
10 mil 396 barriles y de esto el 35% ya
ha sido recuperado mediante las labores
de limpieza del mar y de las playas
según nuestras mejores estimaciones más
temprano un juez peruano prohibió la
salida durante 18 meses a cuatro
directivos de la refinería entre la
lista se encuentran los nombres de jaime
fernández cuesta el director de la
empresa y el de renzo tejada mckenzie el
jefe el terminal marítimo dos de la
pampilla a los que el ministerio público
ordenó a permanecer en el país para
esclarecer los hechos las
investigaciones continúan para
determinar cuál es la responsabilidad de
la empresa en la crisis ambiental
desatada el 15 de enero tras un tsunami
creado por la explosión de un volcán
submarino en tonga
hablamos de otro derrame de crudo
ocurrido en ecuador este viernes tras
una nueva rotura de un oleoducto en la
amazonía dentro de una zona montañosa
amenazada por el proceso de erosión
regresiva del río coca concretamente la
empresa privada oleoducto de crudos
pesados que opera la tubería reveló que
el incidente se debió en parte a una
combinación de terreno debilitado y
fuertes lluvias en el área de piedra
fina que hizo que rocas cayeran sobre el
oleoducto esta es una zona cercana al
volcán reventador que mantiene una
actividad eruptiva permanente
las mujeres uruguayas salieron a las
calles para exigir el fin de las
violaciones feminicidios y demás abusos
en su contra el símbolo de su protesta
fue el ataque grupal ocurrido el domingo
pasado en montevideo contra una mujer de
30 años quien denunció haber sido
abusada por al menos cuatro hombres la
marcha tiñó de violeta a las calles que
iban hacia la plaza independencia donde
se sitúa la sede del gobierno
la cantautora canadiense joni mitchell
quien es una de las principales voces
del folk decidió retirar sus canciones
de la plataforma spotify en protesta por
la emisión de un podcast ha acusado de
difundir noticias falsas sobre el comité
19 y las vacunas así la ganadora de ocho
premios grammy se suma a la acción de su
compatriota
young quien procedió de manera igual
previamente en un comunicado la cantante
dijo que gente irresponsable y mentiras
que cuestan la vida de personas
hasta aquí esta emisión informativa
ustedes quédense con nosotros
[Música]